[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - GORDON
CHAMBERS, "LEAD ME"]
GORDON CHAMBERS: Give it up,
y'all, for Ricky on guitar.
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS:
Give it up for Jaray.
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS:
Give it up for Tia.
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS: Give it
up for Russell, y'all.
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS: We
hope that we led you.
TIA: Give it up for
Gordon Chambers!
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS: We hope
you enjoyed it tonight.
You know why?
[SINGING] Because I
sing because I'm happy.
Didn't I sing because tonight
at Google I felt so free.
His eye is o the the sparrow.
And I know he watches over.
Said I know, he's
always watching over.
I know he watches over Kimberly
Nichole and ABIAH and my new cd
and every sunshine and bee.
Oh yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
GORDON CHAMBERS: Thank you all,
my name is Gordon Chambers.
[APPLAUSE]